We were talking about your son in the commercial break.
And I asked you if I could ask about him.
He is so darn cute and...
Oh, you're so sweet.
(crowd claps)
It's like, I mean, he seems really
like a chip off the old block, if you know what I mean.
Funny and you know, witty.
Do you see yourself in him?
Does he have comedic timing?
'Cause it sounds like he does
when I see him in an interview.
It's really wild.
I mean, I didn't know those things were sort of,
whether it's nature or nurture,
but he has got a wicked sense of humor
and that comic timing, which is interesting,
'cause I don't think that is really taught,
I think that's innate in you.
I agree.
I mean he does live in my house
and we joke around a lot and all that sort of stuff
but I think it's very interesting.
And now he's determined to be a musician.
He's currently playing trombone and tuba,
in his jazz band at school, which is adorable
and loud in my household.
(all laugh)
I voluntarily got him the tuba for the house.
Gotta think through my choices a little bit clearer.
Well he's so funny.
In fact, I have a clip of him.
Can I show it?
Sure.
It's one of his first red carpet experiences.
I think it's from a little while back.
Who else you wanna meet?
Turn that way so I see you, you're so cute.
I dunno.
Just Dr. Who.
We had a party in the limo, didn't we?
You did?
Yes, we got a limo for me-o, limo for me-o.
He's excited about a limo.
I think it might have been the highlight
of the evening for him.
(crowd claps)
I also heard that when she was like,
"How do you like the red carpet?"
He was like, "Well actually it's gold."
Yeah, little too clarifying, little too clarifying.
He's right, it is a gold carpet.
It was a gold carpet that day.
It was the Emmy Awards and it was for,
the cast of "Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt" was nominated...
(Drew screams and claps)
(crowd claps)
Okay, I'm wondering if you will do a quick round
of a few hot topic questions with me, Jane?
Okay.
All right, it's time for, "Before the break."
(crowd cheers and claps)
Okay, who was your best professional kiss?
(Jane gasps) Okay.
Well you never actually saw the kiss,
but I would say it was probably with,
in "National Lampoons Vacation",
"Because daddy says I'm the best at it."
(Drew screams) (Jane laughs)
Oh my God, like my life is complete.
Vicki just said the best line ever about Randy Quaid.
Oh my God, thank you.
I'm like, I am happy.
Okay. What was the last lie you told?
Okay, well, since my son is probably watching this,
I try not to lie.
Maybe every form I've ever filled out ever about my weight.
(all laugh)
I dunno.
Perfect. Okay.
And what was your last Google search?
My last Google search?
It was looking, and I can't say what exactly,
but looking for birthday presents for my son
'cause it's his birthday in about seven days.
Oh my gosh.
So yeah.
So, looking for treats to get him.
You're a good mom.
You're so sweet.
Thank you, and so are you Drew.
(crowd claps)
Jane Krakowski, I love you so much.
(crowd cheers and claps)
I love you so much.
Schmigadoon is so good and so addictive, as I said.
It airs Tuesday at 9, 8 Central, on Fox.
Watch it, enjoy it.
It is just so fun and you are the greatest.
(upbeat theme music)